laissez-moi juste le temps de me mettre
dans la peau d'une personne âgée
c'est incroyable
voilà je porte un simulateur de
vieillissement désormais mes
articulations sont raides mais mouvement
sont limités ma vue est perturbé par un
glaucome ou par une cataracte ou par une
dégénérescence maculaire et ça que vous
pensez mais c'est pas ça c'est pour la
presbyacousie c'est-à-dire la baisse de
l'audition et on va voir comment ça se
passe c'est parti
j'ai dormi sur mon canapé étant donné
que ma chambre est à l'étage et que les
escaliers c'est compliqué
ouais non non plus c'est Pierre même
j'arrive toujours pas à toucher la
manette avec mes doigts une bonne patate
on va partir sur un kebab du coup
pardon
je crois que j'ai marché dans la merde
[Musique]
je suis épuisé